this clip has gone viral this this clip
we played it yesterday let's just play
it again uh marcia blackburn republican
senator from tennessee asked katanji
jackson
can you give a definition
of the word woman
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me
a definition
she can she's not a biologist this clip
has gone viral it's gone viral in part
because this gender issue has taken over
the country you see it with the ncaa
controversy there's a man named will
thomas who beat all the girls in the
girls swimming match and and he gets the
trophy and everyone's supposed to be
okay with that you see it with the
bathroom bills you see it with all sorts
of new legislation and conservatives are
flabbergasted by this we think this is
so
beyond caricature it's so beyond
absurdity
but i i am worried sometimes that we are
not giving the best argument for the
other side or that we simply don't
understand what the other side is saying
so in the interest of actually hearing
out the other side i'm very pleased to
bring on david pakman who is the host of
the david pakman show it's a nationally
syndicated progressive tv show and radio
show i'm always really grateful to
progressives who come on this show we
invite lots of them on very often they
say no sometimes they come on so just to
make sure we're not straw manning
anything uh let's bring on david david
thank you so much for coming on the show
it's a unique pleasure to be here
michael thank you so david
you saw the clip you've been watching
the katanji jackson hearings am i crazy
or should a
twice harvard-educated nominee federal
judge nominee for the supreme court who
is a woman
be able to define what a woman is
i can't say if you're crazy that would
be for a mental health performer for my
doctor you're either dishonest or
ignorant and we can maybe figure out
which so so here's the deal i mean i'm
kind you know what
we're just meeting each other i'm sort
of kidding around but here's the deal um
there are no uh instances where when
issues come before the supreme court
it comes down to the dictionary
definition of a word
when it comes to who counts as a woman
or what is discrimination or what is
negligence
it's always in very narrow circumstances
where dictionary definitions do almost
nothing for you
so she was very smart
not to play into these kind of
rhetorical black holes because whatever
definition she gives michael
she then is going to be pushed into some
corner with some case or article or book
she hasn't read by the way uh and
there's no upside to it so if we're just
having a good faith conversation about
strategy she did the right thing
almost 60 percent of americans believe
she's qualified and she is and that's
really all there is to it it's kind of
boring well i agree with her i don't
agree with you that it's boring i think
it's one of the most interesting
questions in the country that we're now
at a point where we can no longer even
define man or woman but i do agree with
you on strategy she's in a very tough
spot because her side of the aisle and
she's
relatively
leftist even by the standards of the
democratic party so on her side of the
aisle there is a new
definition of woman well they haven't
given the definition of woman but it's
it's not the old definition of woman
which is a person who's not a man that
is out because of the transgender
movement and so she knows that if she
gives this new definition which is a
woman is
i don't know a woman is someone who says
that he or she is a woman that's going
to alienate i think the majority the
vast majority of americans if she gives
the old definition that a woman is
a female human being and a female is of
or denoting the sex that can bear
children and reproduce and you know
produce eggs for instance uh she knows
that that will alienate her base and she
knows that that now is apparently
controversial in the law after the boss
stock decision after other transgender
decisions so i understand the strategy
but what about the law what about the
definition you say she doesn't she
shouldn't be quoting the dictionary well
fine
shouldn't she at least be able to give
the legal definition of a woman
shouldn't she a woman have some sense of
what that is i'm not a meteorologist i
can tell you if it's raining
yeah there is no legal definition of a
woman and that's exactly the point the
point here is when it comes to the court
the court is in a position or will be in
a position or might be in a position to
decide for the purposes of a particular
set of facts
based on a claim brought by someone who
appeals a case about these issues and so
it's it's literally irrelevant to her
job as a supreme court justice and so
again we can have a cultural discussion
outside of the context of the supreme
court in the the senate's job in
evaluating is she qualified it's an
irrelevant question and by her
qualifications she's she's more
qualified than any of the nine justices
currently on the court there's no way to
deny that i think you can because i
think all of the nine justices on the
court can tell you what a woman is
saying so i know we're getting because
they've never been asked to do that no
nobody's ever been asked to define words
in this way during hearings so you could
speculate that but they've never been
asked they've never been asked
impossible i
i've never but i i i as a gambling man i
would bet the farm that justice alito
could tell you what a woman is but
you're right they've never been asked
because it's never been controversial
before but i want to get to a point you
just made you said there's no legal
definition of a woman but there must be
because there are legal protections
specifically for women so if we don't
know what a woman is then title three
thing
good faith conversation or one that's in
some way productive you know
you're saying you and i or you're saying
katanji jackson yeah i don't know if i
mean listen the republican senators
obviously didn't want to have a good
faith conversation i was i was talking
about you and i michael yes well i i do
want to i mean this this is why i'm
granting you the you're making the point
on political strategy i totally grant
you that that was the right move for her
to make if she wants to avoid it
but but then bring up title ix i mean
there are there are legal protections
for women this is coming before the
court it's come before the court in the
last term they're going to be a lot more
cases coming before the court coming up
it seems extraordinarily relevant that
we know what this woman thinks of these
issues and of a basic question of
biology and human nature what is a woman
i mean i i don't think that's a bad
faith question for the senators or for
me to ask no it's so it's not
necessarily bad faith but we have to be
able to as i what i hope are reasonable
people michael understand that in the
context of her role as a supreme court
justice it doesn't come down to a
biological opinion like do is that can
you at least grant that piece it's true
that for what the supreme court decides
these are narrow issues where when it
comes to obamacare's constitutionality
which amy coney barrett never you know
would refuse to weigh in on or that what
with all of these things these are
really narrow legal decisions and there
is no way in which a dictionary
definition definition of terms does
anything for us well it might do
something but i grant your point a
little bit except that marcia blackburn
didn't ask for the biological definition
or the dictionary definition that's what
katanji jackson added she said i'm not a
biologist but all marsha blackburn asked
was just tell me what a woman is from a
legal perspective a constitutional
perspective a philosophical i mean
whatever whatever is literally not what
marsha blackburn said i would encourage
you to pull the clip and identify she's
a name at which she said that she said
she didn't mention biology and she
didn't mention the dictionary she said
but you just asserted that she said she
wanted the legal and philosophical she
never said no no no no no no no no no no
i didn't say that
no no i i just said marsha blackburn
asked for the
definition any sort of definition that
katanji jackson could give of women she
didn't specified by you're backtracking
i'm not backtracking i'm not dishonest
now i'm not back first how am i back
hold on a second let's let's be clear
30 seconds ago you said marsha blackburn
didn't ask for the biological she
actually did illegal no no no no no no
no no no let me let me finish the
sentence
okay but you're misrepresenting what i
said i know i'm not i would encourage
the audience to rewind why i would
encourage that i would encourage that as
well but first but can i even get it out
i mean it's okay the problem with what
you just did michael is you just said
blackburn asked for the legal definition
and i said no she didn't said no that's
true she actually just knows the
definition i'm sorry well then if if
either you misheard or it seemed that i
misspoke i'll be very clear she marcia
blackburn just said what's the
definition of a woman she didn't specify
anything else now you then said that
biology has no place here or that the
dictionary definition has no place but
that's not what marsha blackburn asked
for she just asked a simple question
that in these supreme court hearings
the senators can ask the questions
however they want
and the nominees can answer them however
they want or not answer them my opinion
is this is my opinion and you can have a
different one and that's the great thing
about america michael uh my opinion is
that if you're interviewing for the job
of supreme court justice it's reasonable
to assume the questions have a legal
bearing as to your role on the court
given that
judge jackson was right
to
understand the point of the question is
to back her into a rhetorical corner
about legal definitions and she was
right to say it's not something i can
answer these are narrow issues when they
come before the court and there's no
reason that she would ask such a
question when i do you know this guy
jessie lee peterson have you heard of
him i know jesse lee peterson when i was
on with jesse he said to me david define
what love is and what a man is and it's
a it's a really common rhetorical
technique for the bad faith right to
start with just pick a word and define
it and use it to back someone into a
rhetorical corner it's a waste of time
michael let's take let's talk about real
issues please okay well i i think that
as a
philosophical issue but certainly as a
legal issue too the definition of a
woman
does matter has mattered recently it
will matter soon but but i i i at least
agree with you on the stream you have
not convinced me of uh judge jackson's
uh
good faith uh confirmation hearing but
you have uh convinced me that she is a
wise politician
and that she's uh she's playing her hand
the best that she can
before i let you go david i know we're
like way over i
i'm not i'm really not playing the game
of giving you some impossible thing to
define but since the question of woman
is up in the air everyone's arguing over
what it means these days do you have
either you yourself or you speaking for
the progressives do you have a working
definition that you would use
no i don't do like i told jessie lee
peterson and there's so many that this
this interview is feeling a lot like
that one interestingly enough um i don't
do dictionary i do politics and so now i
just i don't spend time defining words
and here's here's the in all seriousness
michael yeah um
let's now talk philosophically really
we're talking you know man to man now
dictionaries are descriptive not
proscriptive so well they're
prescriptive sometimes too but yeah but
they can be descriptive they can be
they're descriptive and prescriptive as
well right the word
by definition humans decide what to put
in the dictionary right so they're just
the these are scripted but they put it
there because the words at the time
believe
yeah i mean we could we could go down a
tangent on prescriptivism versus
descriptivism and that might be good for
a future appearance to tangent i no it's
it would be a very good discussion and
uh and i i think would be great to have
you back i appreciate that i truly truly
appreciate your coming on and giving uh
the progressive perspective on this and
i hope to have you back on the show
where can people find you in the
meantime
davidpakman.com and it's been my
unbridled pleasure to provide you these
insights
thank you david very much i appreciate
it i'm glad you like that clip now if
you want more clips you got to
ring the bell
subscribe to the michael knowles show
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your podcasts maybe leave a five star
review and go check out my three-part
docu series it is blowing up on the
daily wire i think it might be the most
popular
product we've ever put out on the daily
wire for the daily wire audience it's
called fouchy unmasked it's the behind
the scenes true story you've never seen
this before of dr fauci's rise to power
so go check that out we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you